[Música]
imaginen la película más apocalíptica
que hayan visto
la primera escena es una vista aérea de
la tierra arrasada y el mar renegrido
la mitad de la población mundial lucha
contra la otra mitad por falta de comida
en un lugar desértico
4000 millones de personas viven en zonas
en donde no pueden cultivar nada para
comer y no tienen suficiente agua para
sobrevivir
inundaciones y sequías temperaturas
insoportables nuevas enfermedades que
nos atacan incendios forestales
huracanes muy frecuentes
migraciones masivas cientos de millones
de refugiados ambientales
saqueos de supermercados multiplicados
por miles en todas partes
cortes de electricidad sistemas
financieros y de comunicación caídos
desabastecimiento de agua de combustible
y de medicamentos
un millón de especies desaparecen y no
por una extinción más sino por la
primera aniquilación biológica producida
por una sola especie
pero saben qué
esto no es ciencia ficción esta es una
catástrofe ecológica y climática y es el
mundo de los próximos 10 años
vos en la fila 1 no te vas a salvar vos
en las 5 tampoco vos detrás de la cámara
tampoco yo tampoco porque no importa
donde nos sentemos el colapso nos va a
llevar puestos igual si durante la
próxima década no transformamos nuestro
sistema de producción y consumo
revertimos el avance de la ganadería y
de la agricultura industrial y cortamos
a la mitad el uso de petróleo
esto es cambiarlo todo o casi todo
hoy tengo un par de minutos para
alertarles sobre la gravedad terminal de
nuestra situación
solo un par de minutos para que se
convenzan de que esto no es una teoría
de complot de que estamos realmente
frente a la peor de todas las crisis
nuestra civilización tal cual la
conocemos va a dejar de existir durante
los próximos diez años y no son
responsables de esto las cuatro mil
millones de personas que pueden morir
los principales responsables de haber
llegado a esta situación son quienes
están más preparados para enfrentar el
pronóstico apocalíptico porque escuchan
a la ciencia
los más ricos y poderosos se están
diseñando sus refugios familiares para
sobrevivir al colapso
cuenta un ex gerente de una famosa red
social que cuando comenzó a compartir
con sus colegas de silicon valley los
detalles de su pequeño proyecto de isla
todos comenzaron a salir del closet y a
blanquear sus planes para la
supervivencia
en este preciso momento están comprando
territorios en altura a pueblos enteros
con abundancia natural construyendo
bunkers e instalando generadores paneles
solares y diseñando las milicias para su
defensa
están blindando sus islas privadas
enfrentamos un escenario inevitable de
fragmentación social violenta y hasta
las naciones unidas- los definió sin
tapujos como apartheid climático los
ricos salvándose y la mayor parte de la
humanidad empujada a sobrevivir
existe absoluto consenso de la comunidad
científica superar la barrera de aumento
de la temperatura global en más de 1.5
grados es colapso ecosistémicos masivos
después de los incendios de amazonas
alcanzaremos los 2 grados durante la
próxima década y gracias a 25 años de
negociaciones diplomáticas fallidas
estaremos en 7 grados antes del fin de
siglo
como puede ser que nuestros gobiernos
que tienen toda esta información no
hagan nada
hay algo con buscar las soluciones
dentro del sistema que no está
funcionando
yo misma siento que falle
fallé como activista durante 20 años
porque evidentemente todas las formas de
activismo fallaron fueron insuficientes
hace muy poco toma real dimensión de
esta finitud tan cercana me desesperé y
me llene de ansiedad sabía que nada de
lo que hiciera iba a ser suficiente
también me di cuenta que personas
queridas cuando les hablaba de esto se
iban a otro lado o suspiraba ni me
cambiaban de tema cómo las voy a juzgar
quizás fuera mejor disfrutar de la vida
antes del colapso
pero no pude
y fue imposible seguir como si nada
pasara
entonces llegó el dolor y las ganas de
llorar
aunque no fue lo único
lentamente algo más fue surgiendo desde
el fondo de esa tristeza deje de
obligarme a tener esperanza y apareció
en mí una furia que me energizó me
acelero el corazón y me llevo a la
acción porque lo que necesitaba no era
esperanza
lo que necesitaba era coraje coraje para
cuestionarlo todo para hacerme una
pregunta prohibida
porque tenemos que obedecer las reglas
del sistema que nos está exterminando
es lógico seguir alentando la producción
ganadera y agro tóxica si sabemos que
devasta comunidades y ecosistemas
enteros
es justo que nuestros impuestos subsidio
en proyectos petroleros de fracking
la extracción no convencional de
combustibles fósiles acelera el desastre
climático
la complicidades de las instituciones me
duelen las entrañas pero no es la
primera vez que somos testigos de un
genocidio silencioso
en otros momentos de la historia
existieron procesos de exterminio
masivos que buscaron ser ocultados por
las autoridades
esta vez tenemos que desafiar a la
autoridad injusta a tiempo porque cuando
las leyes y las instituciones no nos
protegen el contrato social desaparece
y los ciudadanos adquirimos el derecho y
el deber a la desobediencia civil
quizás se pregunten si lo que planteo es
una suerte de rebelión lo que planteo es
que este modelo es autodestructivo
porque está fundado en negar los límites
físicos del planeta y si uno suficiente
con que lo digan las naciones unidas
sólo plantee yo acá vayan a las redes
está lleno de fuentes confiables
pero frente a esta verdad científica los
gobiernos nos responden que es política
y socialmente imposible cambiar tan
rápido sin embargo ya hemos
protagonizado cambios radicales en
momentos de emergencia que parecían
imposibles por ejemplo durante las
guerras
esta es la emergencia más enorme a la
que nos hayamos enfrentado nos quedan
menos de 10 años para una transformación
de proporciones épicas que no vamos a
conseguir solamente poniendo molinos
eólicos paneles solares reciclando o
reduciendo nuestro consumo individual de
carne necesitamos la movilización de
personas más grandes de la historia
quienes han estudiado el éxito de los
movimientos civiles de resistencia
demostraron que si el 3.5 por ciento de
la población sostiene en el tiempo
estrategias de disrupción pacífica
llevando a las calles un reclamo justo
podemos acudir a un sistema que se niega
a escuchar
la desobediencia civil no violenta ha
sido el método más efectivo a lo largo
de la historia reciente para lograr
cambios sistémicos y radicales existen
muchos ejemplos bien conocidos rosa
parks martin luther king gandhi
las colectivas de mujeres que exigieron
y lograron el voto femenino y hoy siguen
dando luchas imprescindibles
nuestro país tiene experiencias hermosas
de desobediencia civil pacífica y
exitosa principalmente en la ruralidad
el pueblo de malvinas argentinas en
córdoba bloqueó la instalación de
monsanto en su tierra instalando durante
cuatro años la disrupción colectiva
la comunidad de famatina en la rioja
lleva más de una década expulsando a las
mineras más grandes del mundo a pesar de
las reglas y las normas escritas
no hay gradualismo cuando estamos
luchando por nuestra supervivencia
los fenómenos de transformación
planetarios no se van a detener por una
ley
no podemos frenar con un decreto a las
millones de personas que estarán
cruzando fronteras escapando de
fenómenos climáticos extremos
quizás en este momento estén queriendo
volver al mundo que conocían hace 10
minutos pero no tengo alternativa no
tenemos alternativa
con creatividad y sin violencia tenemos
que salir a la calle para cambiarlo todo
la transformación tiene que empezar hoy
y tiene que ser enorme y
desproporcionada más allá de lo posible
la única decisión que podemos tomar en
estos momentos de incertidumbre es qué
hacer con el tiempo que tenemos nadie lo
va a hacer por nosotros el poder real
nos pertenece abracemos lo
con amor y furia
el tiempo no es mucho
y para que sea justo
debe ser desobediente
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
[Aplausos]